الى ذلك اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال احياء عده
في مدينه جنين وفي اطراف مخيمها واعتقلت
ثلاثه شبان الفلسطينيين بينما اصيب اخر
بجروح وافاد مراسل الجزيره باندلاع اشتباك
بين قوه الاحتلال ومقاومين فلسطينيين
اطلقوا الرصاص واستخدموا العبوات ضد وحده
مستعربين في جيش الاحتلال دخلت الى
المدينه والى اطراف المخيم مستخدمه مركبات
فلسطينيه وقلم راسل الجزيره ان قناصه من
جنود الاحتلال اعتلوا عمارات مطله على
المخيم واعتدوا بالضرب على بعض السكان قبل
انسحابهم
من مخيم بلاطه شرقيه نابلس تنظموا الي
مراسله الجزيره جيفارا الموديري مرحبا
جيفارا ابرز ما حدث منذ منتصف الليله
الماضيه في كل من بلاطه
وجنين وايضا في بلدات اخرى في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله
بدايه في هذه الاثناء محمد تجرى اعدادات
لتشييع جثمان الشهداء الجثمين الشهداء
الثلاثه الجنازه ستنطلق من مستشفى رفيديا
وسط مدينه نابلس باتجاه دوار الشهداء وسط
المدينه وصولا الى هنا الى مخيم بلاطه
لتشييع جثامين الشهداء الثلاثه الذين
ارتقوا برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وكاله كتائب شهداء الاقصى الذراع المسلح
لحركه فتح قد نعت الشهداء الثلاثه واكدت
ان اثنين منهما هما من عناصرها وان
العمليه العسكريه التي قامت بها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وشارك بها المئات وفق
بيان
لقوات الاحتلال هذه العمليه شارك بها
المئات من جنود الاحتلال من وحدات مختلفه
كدفان المستعربين الشباب
والويه مختصه
السبعين لنكبه الفلسطينيه هنا يقولون
النكبه لم تنتهي هي لا زالت متواصله بطبع
كانت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وحتى وليس
كالمعتاد بان تقوم
بالاعلام العائي العائلات بانها ستفجر
المنزل قامت بتبجير المنزل وهم في داخل
المنزل لم يتضرر منزل واحد بل يعني على
الاقل تضرر سبع منازل من بينها ثلاثه
اربعه منازل تضررت نتيجه التفجير البنايه
السكنيه قايله الان للسقوط ولكن مع ذلك ما
اكده لنا عدد من عناصر كتائب شهداء الاقصى
هنا في المخيم ان المقاومه متواصله لن
تتوقف فور انسحاب قوات الاحتلال من مخيم
بلاطه بعد عمليه عسكريه واسعه كانت اشبه
هنا وسط وصف الاهالي بالسياح عام
وهو الاشياح الاكبر للضفه الغربيه على
الفور كان هناك اجتياح اخر لمدينه جنين
وعده احياء فيها وعلى اطراف المخيم تم
اعتقال عدد من الشبان الفلسطينيين واندلعت
اشتباكات مسلحه بين قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وعدد من المقاومين الفلسطينيين
وفق بيان لخوات الاحتلال فانه تم اعتقال
13 فلسطينيا من انحاء مختلفه من الضفه
الغربيه خلال عمليات اقتحام نفذتها بالطبع
هنا في بلاطه على الاقل خمسه تم اعتقالهم
ولكن ايضا في جنين ثلاثه والباقي هم من
مختلفه من قرى وبلدات الضفه الغربيه حاله
من الغضب حاله من الحزن تسود كافه ارجاء
محافظه نابلس وبالطبع الضفه الغربيه نابلس
يسودها الاضراب الشامل با المدارس حدادا
على ارواح الشهداء الذين سقطوا حسب وصف
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه في هذه
المجزره وبالتالي واضح ان اخبار جنين
ونابلس ستبقى تتصدر المشهد الميداني
والسياسي بعض المراقبين يرون ان نتنياهو
يحاول تسليط الضوء على الوضع الميداني على
الارض في الضفه الغربيه لابعاد الانظار
تماما عن الاحتجاجات المتواصله ضده وضد
سياساته والاصطلاحات القضائيه وخاصه ايضا
يعني لم ينتهي الوضع حتى في حواره بعدما
حدث بالامس والادعاء بان فلسطيني قام
بتنفيذ عمليه دهس وادت الى اصابه جندي
اسرائيلي بجراح خطيره رغم انه حتى الان لم
يؤكد ذلك رسميا من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك يا جيفارا
المدير من مخيم بلاطه شرقيه نابلس